if you manage to pass third grade math
you might be having trouble following GM
CEO ed Whitaker's explanation of how
General Motors has paid back its
government bailout in full and ahead of
schedule
that's because Whitaker is passing more
gas than a Hummer GM got 50 billion
dollars in a bailout from tarp funds and
the government got a majority ownership
of GM stock part of the bailout came in
the form of a straight-up 6.7 billion
dollar loan and part of it came as an
escrow account worth thirteen point four
billion that GM could tap into his work
in capital when GM brags about paying
back its loan it's talking about the six
point seven billion which it repaid with
money from the escrow account do you
remember when you were a kid and your
parents gave you $20 to buy them a
Christmas present you would buy them
something worth three dollars and you
would pocket the rest well that's what
GM just did and do you remember hitting
your parents up for college
well GM is also applying for a ten
billion dollar low-interest loan to
retool its plants so it's cars can meet
the government's new gas mileage
standards if you call that paying back
your debts in full and ahead of schedule
you might just want to check out the new
line of GM cars and hope that their
safety engineers are better at math than
their CEO for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie